there's been a whole slate of layoffs at
Major media companies in recent weeks
and rather than tell you about it or
read something about it I will let
Taylor Loren who's the Washington Post
propagandist one of their many
propagandist they have on the payroll
she recorded a video very very
distraught and upset about the state of
the media now and how they're all losing
their jobs and let's listen to her
journalism industry is basically in a
free fall today the Los Angeles Times
laid off5 employees they wiped out their
entire DC Bureau in an election year
they laid off pretty much all the their
sports teams they killed their entire
Tech and business section they laid off
breaking news writers social media
editors the list goes on but what's
really dark is this is just the latest
in months and months and months of
layoffs in the media industry she's
saying all this like it's a bad thing
and she wants us to be upset but
everyone is receiving it as uh as
glorious news so this is like she's
basically telling us that it's Christmas
morning but she wants us to be sad about
it